mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
a smartphone uses a four-digit passcode
like zero one three one
san wants to reset the passcode such
that the new passcode cannot have the
digit 1 followed by the digit 3.
how many different passcodes can be
formed
this is adapted from the 2019 spm paper
in malaysia i thank george tan for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we'll get started by noticing the total
number of passcodes equals the total
number of passcodes with one followed by
three plus the total number without one
followed by 3.
we can rearrange this equation and
calculate the first and second
quantities to get the third quantity
the reason is that these will be easier
to calculate
how many passcodes are possible
there are four different spots which can
each have up to 10 different digits
so each spot can have a total number of
10 possibilities
the total number of passcodes for four
digits will be the product of 10 10 10
and 10
this will equal 10 to the power of 4
which equals 10 000.
now let's calculate the total number of
passcodes with 1 followed by 3.
one way that we can get a passcode with
one followed by three is to have one and
three in the first two spots
then we can have ten possibilities for
the third spot and ten possibilities for
the fourth spot
this will be a total of ten times ten or
100 possibilities
we can also have 1 and 3 in the second
and third spots
just as before this will be a total of
100 possibilities because the other two
spots can have 10 possibilities each
we could also have one and three in the
third and fourth spots and this will be
a total of 100 possibilities
but we have to be careful when we're
counting
the code 1313 is counted in both the
first and the third situations
we've double counted this code
therefore we need to subtract one to get
the total number of passcodes with one
followed by three
this will be equal to 100 plus 100 plus
100
minus 1 because we've double counted 13
13. this will therefore be equal to 299
we can then take 10 000 minus 299 and
get the answer that there are 9701
passcodes without one followed by three
it's a challenging problem if you don't
know how to solve it but with practice
this is a routine calculation and i hope
you watch more of these videos so that
this problem will be easy for you
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you